[Music]
Brittney's no Daisy Ridley and more hey
guys what Oh weeks for fashion some of
our favorite starlets slayed the red
carpet at major movie premieres this
week and I've got all the fun details on
what they wore first up Daisy Ridley at
the world premiere of Star Wars of the
last Jedi in Los Angeles the forest was
definitely where the 25 year old that
was cheesy but seriously she looks like
a galactic princess in this Navy
sequined gown with star detailing all
over the place
it's by montsum a sauna and retails for
eight thousand six hundred bucks
my lovely stylist put me in stars what
can I say Daisy added strappy heels by
Christian Louboutin and check out those
rings by penny prevail together they
sell for nearly six thousand five
hundred bucks I was really nervous like
an hour ago
and then I got here and it was like
weirdly calm out there Lupita Nyong'o
was also a fashion force at the premiere
who are you wearing I'll turn yep
thirty-four-year-old radiated in this
emerald Halford gown she paired the look
with strappy Jimmy Choo heels the price
seven hundred and ninety five dollars
and check out that clutch by Tyler Ellis
she finished off the look with over two
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
worth jewels by Tiffany and Co with
great that it's been received with so
much love and admiration on Tuesday
Britney snow turned heads at her Los
Angeles movie premiere for pitch perfect
three thirty one-year-old stunned in
this black Monique Lhullier gown with
colorful floral embellishments it feels
like me I when I tried it on I was like
oh this was meant to fit my body because
I have like man shoulders and things
that I don't like but it like makes it
okay she looked more than okay and added
these Jimmy Choo heels worth 895 bucks
and last Jessica vo the actress looked
effortlessly chic leaving a restaurant
in Los Angeles on Monday the floral mini
dress by a frm retails for just one
hundred and eighteen dollars an hour
Sony's are by Hayes
retail for 300 bucks all right guys who
gets your vote for Best Dressed of the
week was it one of these celebs or
someone else you can always let us know
in the comments or send me a tweet bye
for now
[Music]
you